HAVE THEM.
ALSO TOMORROW I WILL BE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
INTERVIEWING VICE PRESIDENT
PENCE.
SEND ME YOUR QUESTIONS.
♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
SENT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP RAN FOR
OFFICE TO FIX WASHINGTON AND
MAKE GOOD DEALS AND DO A
BETTER JOB THAN THE CORRUPT
LAWMAKERS HE SAID WERE
WRECKING THE COUNTRY.
HE WAS RIGHT THEY WERE
TODAY IN REMARKABLE TWIST
THE PRESIDENT HELD A
TELEVISED MEETING WITH THE
VERY SWAMP CREATURES HE
WANTS DENOUNCED.
HE TOLD THEM HE TRUSTED THEM
TO CRAFT IMMIGRATION POLICY
WITHOUT HIS INPUT THEN HE
SAID HE WOULD BE WILLING TO
ACCEPT ANY DEAL THEY
PRODUCED EVEN A BAD ONE.
>> WHEN THIS GROUP COMES
BACK HOPEFULLY WITH AN
AGREEMENT, THIS GROUP AND
OTHERS FROM THE SENATE, FROM
THE HOUSE, COMES BACK WITH
AN AGREEMENT, I'M SIGNING
IT.
I MEAN, I WILL BE SIGNING IT
I'M NOT GOING TO SAY OH GEE,
I WANT THIS OR I WANT THAT.
I WILL BE SIGNING IT BECAUSE
I HAVE A LOT OF CONFIDENCE
IN THE PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM
THAT YOU WILL COME UP WITH
SOMETHING REALLY GOOD.
>> Tucker: AT ONE POINT THE
PRESIDENT AGREED WITH
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR DIANNE
FEINSTEIN OF CALIFORNIA THAT
IT WOULD BE WISE TO HANDLE
THE QUESTION OF DACA
SEPARATELY BEFORE
NEGOTIATING ANY MEANINGFUL
SYSTEM.
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU
WOULD FEEL ABOUT THIS BUT I
WHAT ABOUT A CLEAN DACA BILL
NOW WITH A COMMITMENT THAT
WE GO IN TO A COMPREHENSIVE
IMMIGRATION REFORM PROCEDURE
LIKE WE DID BACK, I REMEMBER
WHEN KENNEDY WAS HERE, IT
WAS REALLY A MAJOR, MAJOR
EFFORT AND IT WAS GREAT
DISAPPOINTMENT THAT IT WENT
NOWHERE.
>> I REMEMBER THAT.
>> I HAVE NO PROBLEM.
I THINK THAT'S BASICALLY
DACA.
WE ARE GOING TO DO DACA AND
COMPREHENSIVE.
>> YEAH, I WOULD LIKE.
>> Tucker: KEY ALLIES TO THE
PRESIDENT ON IMMIGRATION
TOLD US THIS AFTERNOON THEY
WERE SHOCKED BY WHAT THEY
DIFFERENT DONALD TRUMP FROM
THE ONE WE WATCHED ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL JUST TWO
YEARS AGO.
HOW DIFFERENT?
LET'S PUT IT THIS WAY.
TRUMP'S RIVAL FROM THE 2016
RACE JEB BUSH WHO WAS ON THE
FAR LEFT OF REPUBLICAN
WORDS IN RESPONSE TO THE
MEETING.
BIPARTISAN SOLUTIONS TO OUR
IMMIGRATION CHALLENGES.
IN 2016, DONALD TRUMP RAN ON
THE PREMISE THAT AMERICA'S
BORDERS OUGHT TO BE REAL.
THAT THE REPEATED AMNESTIES
OF THE PAST HAVE BETRAYED
VOTERS AND THAT THIS COUNTRY
AMERICAN INTERESTS.
RATHER THAN THOSE OF FOREIGN
COUNTRIES.
ALMOST NOBODY IN WASHINGTON
AGREED WITH HIM AT THE TIME,
AGREES WITH HIM NOW.
CONGRESS IS FULL OF PEOPLE
FROM BOTH PARTIES WHO
BELIEVE THAT THE POINT OF
OUR IMMIGRATION POLICY IS TO
PROVIDE CHEAP LABOR TO THEIR
DONORS AND TO ATONE FOR
AMERICA'S IMAGINARY SINS
AGAINST THE WORLD.
THEY COULDN'T CARE LESS
ABOUT IMMIGRATION'S EFFECT
ON YOU OR YOUR FAMILY.
IF THESE ARE THE SAME PEOPLE
THE PRESIDENT NOW SAYS HE
TRUSTS TO WRITE THE
IT SAYS.
SO WHAT WAS THE POINT OF
PRESIDENT ALSO RAN ON HIS
SKILLS AS A NEGOTIATOR AND
HE CLEARLY HAS SKILLS AS A
NEGOTIATOR.
WHERE WERE THEY TODAY?
THE PRESIDENT SIGNALED HE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS NOW AND
THAT AT SOME POINT IN THE
FUTURE TACKLE ALL THAT OTHER
STUFF LIKE MAKING SURE THEY
CAN'T BRING MILLIONS OF
THEIR RELATIVES FROM THE
NEGOTIATION.
AMNESTY FOR DACA RECIPIENTS
IS THE ONLY LEVERAGE THE
WHITE HOUSE HAS.
ONCE THE PRESIDENT AGREES TO
NEGOTIATION IS OVER.
AT THAT POINT WHY WOULD
DEMOCRATS AGREE TO ANYTHING?
ENDING CHAIN MIGRATION, THE
SYSTEM THAT MIGHT ACTUALLY
THE DEMOCRATS' GOAL IS TO
IMPORT MORE DEMOCRATIC
VOTERS AND BY ANY MEANS
NECESSARY.
ONCE THEY RETAKE THE
CONGRESS AND THE PRESIDENCY
AND IF TRUMP BETRAYS BASE ON
IMMIGRATION THAT WILL
DEFINITELY HAPPEN IT IS
OVER.
SAY GOODBYE TO BORDERS.
THEY ARE DONE.
KEEP IN MIND THAT THE TOP
DEMOCRAT IN THE HOUSE
RECENTLY THANKED ILLEGAL
ALIENS FOR SNEAKING INTO
THIS COUNTRY.
THAT'S HOW DEMOCRATS FEEL
AND THEY ARE NOT PRETENDING
ANYMORE.
BEING A TRUMP VOTER ISN'T
ALWAYS EASY, IT'S LIKE
ROOTING FOR THE UNDERDOG IN
BASEBALL.
THE OLD CHICAGO CUBS.
ON ONE LEVEL THERE IS PRIDE,
THE PRIDE THAT COMES FROM
DOING SOMETHING THAT
FASHIONABLE PEOPLE CONSIDER
INSANE.
DISAPPOINTMENT ALONG THE WAY
AND HONESTLY THERE IS SOME
EMBARRASSMENT.
YOU SIGH LENGTHSLY BEAR IT
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHEN THEY
FINALLY WIN THE WORLD SERIES
IT WILL BE WORTH EVERYTHING
YOU WENT THROUGH.
EVERY SARCASTIC DIG FROM
YOUR BROTHER-IN-LAW AT
THANKSGIVING WILL SEEM SMALL
WORLD SERIES IS THIS